when beauty and the beast came out in
1991 it was debut in the cinema and i
was just jaw-dropped when i saw the
first scene of belle you know she came
out the village and then and then the
whole story about the bees in an
enchanted castle it was just so purely
magical and it really gets me you know
and it was breathtaking
to watch
and
i still feel goosebump when i watch it
until now
beauty and the beast is probably the
animated movie that i
felt like
this is it
i've been dreaming about this house
since i was a child i wanted to feel
when i go to the house i'm in the
disneyland itself
and i thought about it and said okay
i need to make this happen
hi my name is david and my instagram
page is devda so i'm a graphic designer
and welcome to my disney home
i moved into singapore about nine years
ago and i got my citizenship i'm very
happy at that time i started collecting
some of the stuff
like memorabilia of disney the figurines
from jim shore
funko pops
musical figurine soft toys dvds
some of the sketches stationary i have
pins as well
wall disney classic collections
porcelain that's the one that are always
adored because they are so precise they
are really work with the animator itself
to create that figurine you can never
get now because they are quite
expensive and rare limited edition dolls
is the one that i felt like
so connected to it because
the level of craftsmanship that disney
artists put into just one doll it was
amazing so as i start working i start to
buying slightly more expensive stuff
some of them can cost up more than a few
hundred dollars so sometimes it's really
hard to get things that
really what you wanted especially your
favorite characters
pretty much lost count of how many i've
got because
i don't intend to sell anyway i just
thought about what i liked and i wanted
to have all this because i
don't have much of this privilege to
have all these toys when i was a child
of course i wanted to get something
that is
from the man himself which is i think
it's important i have a few things from
walt disney's office thought about it
like we need to know this guy i mean
really admire his passion so d23 always
have this memorabilia gift
where you can actually get it from the
disney archives disney archives is the
company where they kept all
historical stuff based on walt disney's
era life and until now until today so
d22 gave this piece of history of
what is inside the wall disney desk so i
have the wall disney signature as a
replica and i have the walt disney
telegram i think he sent this telegram
toward kimball where kimble is one of
the animators as well who did cinderella
and also there's a few other things
inside i put this all together for
disney and how much i love disney
hopefully that if you can see that you
will be proud getting a staff
merchandise for disney is always very
challenging there's always a certain
limitations that disney usually
gave up to people to buy nasa and honor
this is very expensive because she's
only limited to 2500 ps worldwide when i
purchased it for 1 000
for elsa
and he came to singapore it was in the
bad conditions everything is broken the
hairs go like i was i was so heartbroken
when i received it so that's the thing
when you purchase something from online
you make sure that you ask all these
photos and make sure that
it has to be very clearly how it looks
like another one is probably beauty and
the beast the platinum one that
particular one i've actually managed to
get it online on the launch itself
so i'm quite lucky i'm one of the
few hundred people 500 people who got
that platinum and those platinum now i
think cost probably about
four to five
k us dollars now because it's just so
limited and
it's one of the best
collections so far for the platinum set
my first experience at disneyland was in
hong kong i was
i think it was 24 if i can't mistake
i was like
oh my god i can't believe that this is
this is happening this is this is
something that
people talk about oh disneyland is
something that you can go as a theme
park you go for the rides and that kind
of thing but i never felt
being so touched just the minute i came
up on the mtr you know and i felt like
all the songs that i've been listening
to
and the soundtrack the movies the
classic and everything
it just brings back two memories and of
course i got tears myself when
when i walk into the
and i see the magic castle it was just
like
i can't believe that i'm here and i
never thought that this place could
bring me
touch my heart and bring me tears all
the time then my mom's crying why you
say why are you crying why are you
crying i said i'm not crying i'm just
being crying tears of happiness
when people say disney is for kids to me
i think disney is for everybody
it's for all ages
i strongly believe of what ward's vision
he creates for every single people
to be able to enjoy it
if we can enjoy being a kids why not you
know
life doesn't always has to be serious
all the time
basically
free
you know you don't have any things in
your head taking pictures of my
collections it's a passion for me to
take photos and i like disney so much
eventually
the followers getting
higher and higher sometimes i get a lot
of kind of messages from my followers
and they're really happy what they see
people likes the pictures and some of
them even say that your pictures have a
soul and your pictures really tells the
story
some of my followers they really help me
they support me so without them i would
never be as what i am now today so i
think it's it's kind of like give and
take
being an influencer you can always
direct people to be more positive being
together you know help each other one
another and no matter what age you are
no matter what culture you are no matter
what race you are
there's always a magic
the thought about it of helping this
society i think it's
it's truly my plan
you know maybe work together with
disney and i would like to share the
magic to everyone elderly or somebody in
the community where i felt like
we needed to have
the feel of love and
help one another so that they can
be as happy as i am
[Music]
you